hey guys it's max we just got in our
brand new note 20 ultra that i purchased
and today i'm going to be comparing it
to
my iphone 11 pro max and i'm not just
going to cover the typical stuff like
specs and performance
i want to know how good is the display
how good are the speakers and how good
are
other things that actually matter in the
real world apart from just the raw
performance now before we jump in
and take a look at all those great
things i want to give a shout out to our
merch
this t right here the premium one is
super comfortable check it out in the
merch shelf down below
and if you need a face mask for yourself
we have a matching one
these things have been selling like
crazy so make sure you go
and check that out let's get this bad
boy opened up and as i open this i want
to say that
six months ago or so with the s20 ultra
i was really tempted
to switch over to that phone i really
liked it there were a few things that
held me back
such as the slow autofocus autofocus
system on there
but this time around i'm going to be
switching over for at least a week and
then comparing it to the iphone
experience and there's a chance that i
might just stick with using
this samsung especially that 5g is
really nice for me so
giving you my first impressions i got
the color that kind of matches with the
iphone it's a little bit darker
but i really love the look here this
thing
feels lighter than my iphone even though
you guys can see how much
larger it is it's taller so that's very
interesting this camera bump is
absolutely massive the s20 ultras was
big
way bigger than the iphones this one it
seems like they made it even bigger
let me compare it to the s20 ultra
and definitely the actual unit itself is
a little bit slimmer but it sticks out
more
and that's mostly because the note 20
ultra if you guys could tell is actually
thinner than the s20 ultra
and holding in the hand the s20 ultra is
way heavier
and it's not as comfortable to hold
because of the curved edges and how slim
it is on the sides
it actually feels surprisingly
lightweight and more comfortable it's
actually a little bit slimmer
than the iphone 11 pro max you could
definitely tell that they're taking some
design
cues from the iphone with those rings
around the cameras
and i have to say it looks way better
than the one on the s20
ultra and we could see that little laser
auto focusing
edition that they added and that was one
of the biggest annoyances with the s20
ultra both for photos and videos was the
autofocus
was quite a bit worse than the previous
ones so that's going to be a good
improvement now
as i mentioned i like how slim it feels
and one reason is because it has a 4500
milliamp battery instead of 5000 i know
we're not comparing it to this one
we're comparing it to the iphone which
has just under a 4
000 milliamp hour battery but of course
the screen
doesn't match up so this will get a
little bit less battery life than your
iphone now to charge them up
it actually comes with a 25 watt charger
instead of let me pull it out here
the 18 watt charger that apple gives you
and it charges in just over an hour
compared to two hours for the iphone so
it charges a lot faster
and if you're somebody that bought one
of these 45 watt chargers for your s20
ultra
it actually won't take 45 watts if you
plug it in with this it'll still
take only 25 watts just like the
included charger so don't spend the
extra money on it finishing up with the
design
the iphone has the power button on the
right hand side which is convenient if
you use it and then it has
your volume rockers and your mute switch
on the left hand side
i like how the note has everything on
the right hand side being right-handed i
can turn off the screen i can adjust the
power of course we don't have that
physical mute switch which i really like
on the iphones
let's go ahead and set up our
fingerprint scanner and i have to say
that actually got fairly good starting
with the s20 series and as you guys
could see
this thing works incredibly quickly
seems like it's faster than before
and you don't even have to turn on the
screen in order to turn it on with the
iphone
you can either lift it up to have the
screen turn on if you have the option
enabled and then swipe
up or you tap on the screen first and
then swipe up but it's really quick as
you guys could see
but with that said in times like these
if you have one of these
awesome comfortable breathable max tech
masks or any other one
it won't let you load up you have to put
in your password and if you thought
about doing a secondary alternate
appearance
no it does not let you set it up so
you're back to the old age of typing
in your password each time let me tell
you it's very annoying
with the note 20 you press it bam you're
in
that is very convenient for times like
these and if you haven't bought one of
these
go check out the workshelf down below
now before we compare the displays which
is going to be interesting
i want to do a speaker comparison so get
your best pair of headphones
i want to mention that i did turn on
dolby atmos on the note 20 ultra which
does make it sound
better let's go ahead and get into it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
there you guys go let me know your
thoughts down in the comment section
below of course we're recording through
a mic it's going through youtube so i'll
give you guys my opinions
overall wow the note 20 ultra sounds
fantastic
samsung has been doing a great job with
their speakers on their tablets on their
phones they keep
improving it and what really stood out
to me is
not only is it louder but the sound is
pleasant the mid sound really rich
the vocals sound very natural very very
pleasant
the iphone sounds more harsh it doesn't
sound as
full but there is one area where the
iphone is a little bit better
the bass is a little bit deeper sounds
less poppy and
the speakers are more evenly balanced it
sounds like samsung this year
put a little bit more output on the
bottom speaker it's not bad
but it's not as balanced as the iphone
overall if i had to choose one it would
definitely be the samsung though
and now let's talk about the displays
and boy is there a lot to talk about
right off the bat you guys see
there's a huge difference in the design
the note uses a square display with
very thin bezels especially on the sides
compared to even bezels that are much
thicker on the iphone
and we have this notch here the iphone
looks like a much older design this
looks more futuristic
and the screen is also quite a bit
larger 6.9
inches even though this actually the
phone is lighter and slightly narrower
more comfortable to hold
this has a 91 screen to body ratio
it's the smallest phone with this size
of a screen which is impressive now as
far as
the quality the iphone has a 2.7 million
pixel
screen on the note you get a choose and
i have it in the mode
that has 2.4 million pixels but you can
also go up to 4.4
much higher but then you're gonna be
losing out on
one of the key features and that is the
refresh rate
the iphone does only 60 hertz it is
stuck there
where the note 20 ultra could do 120
hertz and not only gonna do that just
like the s20
it can actually be adaptive because it's
using a new display technology
so if you're watching a 24 frames per
second movie it'll drop
down to that to save you battery life
now how is the screen
quality having a little bit less pixels
but a larger screen
when you're using that 120 hertz mode to
be honest if i'm looking at about this
distance about a foot away maybe a
little bit less
i could tell that the iphone is slightly
sharper when i'm looking
at text at normal distance a little bit
further away it's going to be hard to
tell the difference
and then of course if you care about
pure quality which sometimes i would
turn on if i'm watching a movie i would
go into that high resolution mode
now as far as viewing angles they are
surprisingly
very very close the samsung does have
slightly more contrast because the
screen is a little bit more
reflective now let's go ahead and max
out the brightness on these screens
as you can tell the iphone is much
brighter and that's with the high
performance mode
on adaptive brightness turned off
samsung just doesn't let your screen get
that bright if you're using the manual
controls especially with a full white
screen
if you guys can see right here if i go
into the small mode it's much brighter
here
and then just dims right away to save
battery light and heat now the iphone
will also dim
down if you're outside in the sun and
it's getting hot
but the samsung if you leave it in that
auto mode
it will allow it to get brighter as you
guys can see right here the note just
wants to know that you actually need
that brightness before it gives it to
you so you have less control on the note
and outside with the full white screen
they're very similar with some text they
know it's slightly brighter actually
so if you need the extra brightness make
sure to keep it in that adaptive mode
and now for the final display test how
well do these phones
play back videos on youtube i have a 4k
hdr video
open here and i usually complain that
the iphone will only give you a 1080p
option but with the latest software we
actually can select
up to 4k hdr 60 frames per second on my
iphone which is great and on the note
now it's the one that's actually limited
to 1440p 60fps hdr when you have it in
the high resolution mode
so it's actually a little bit lower but
the screen has more pixels let's see
how that stacks up in actual playback
wow this is
interesting the iphone not only looks
sharper because that 4k
over sampling but the hdr is brighter as
well with more contrast
the s20 ultra is actually a little bit
better for hdr than the iphone the same
iphone so i wonder what the latest
software updates
if i the apple is pushing the screens
more and we have that extra detail but
it definitely does
look better now unfortunately i can't
say that much
for um the performance of the phone it
does not have 5g
4k is a lot of data right here we're
stuck with buffering
uh because it can't handle that amount
of bandwidth whereas the samsung's in
the last couple times i've switched over
they do much better especially with that
5g now the last thing i have to say
about the screens before we go into
performance
is the fact that with these squared off
edges
and with a little camera cut out you see
a lot more of the video compared to the
rounded edges on the iphone and with the
notch
and now let's get into performance the
note 20 ultra has a new snapdragon 865
plus and that's because one of these
cores
instead of being at 2.84 gigahertz now
runs up to 3.09
so single core performance should be
really good
let's go ahead and start our cpu
benchmark and here we have it
surprisingly the multi-core score is
very close now the a13 bionic which
is an almost year-old chip is still
beating out
the latest and greatest snapdragon 865
plus by a little bit in the multi-core
but the single core score is over
40 faster so having that extra core
running out 3.08 gigahertz
still didn't help out enough giving the
samsung
you know delete or even getting it close
to matching up apple is still fantastic
with their chips now let's take a look
at antutu
which is going to give us a broader test
interestingly
the note actually looks a little bit
smoother and vadim just pointed out that
it's because it has that 120 hertz
screen vadim is going to be doing a
detailed gaming comparison so if you
guys want to see that
let us know which games you're
interested in down below and make sure
you guys have those notifications
enabled and we just gotta score back
and wow i was not expecting this the
note 20 ultra is getting more than a
hundred thousand more points
close to 120 000 more than our iphone
so if we look at just the cpu that is
beating out the iphone which is
interesting because geekbench 5 didn't
and then we look at the graphics the
graphics is actually doing better as
well
and in the little gaming section we
could tell that it was running smoother
now this is the part that really gets me
going down to the memory
the score on the note 20 ultra is almost
twice
as good now for the first part
we have a difference in ram we have four
gigs of ram on the iphone compared to 12
on the note and let me tell you that 4
gig limit is annoying on the iphone
i keep coming up to apps that are
closing on me automatically
especially when i go to take photos or
if i have multiple apps open it is
annoying
you don't have an issue with the note 20
and not only is the speed really fast
but the storage internally the rom
section right here
we go from 4 000 read to 26
000 the memory in here the storage is
ultra fast
and the right speed from 000 to 10
600 and then the random access is also
from 2600 to 15 000.
samsung put in the latest chips in here
better than the s20 ultra good
improvement over that
and it definitely shows now as far as
the ux the smoothness
it's very similar slightly better on the
notes of course they're not factoring in
the display and when you have that 120
hertz everything feels much smoother
and much quicker and snappier
realistically though both of these are
gonna do a fantastic job and if you're
gonna keep a phone for say
three four five years the iphone's
probably the way to go it has software
updates
it's gonna still keep performing really
nicely
now let's go ahead and get into the
cameras we started out with the camera
bumps we're going to talk about that now
this thing looks really nice it has a
108 megapixel camera system
just like the s20 ultra it has 10 on the
front which is weird it's a little bit
less than 4k so they're up sampling it
and we have that super zoom camera the
iphone is limited to 10 times
zoom so here's a comparison between the
two at 10 times
of course the iphone also has the deep
fusion text so let me know which one of
these
looks better here's a series of images
you guys take a look and let me know
what looks best
we're going to be doing a detailed
unbiased
blind comparison between these two those
are always so much fun to shoot
and to record for you guys so make sure
you guys have those notifications
enabled
to get a true detailed sense of how
these two stack up
before i give you guys my final
conclusion there are two unique features
with both of these phones that i have to
mention
the iphone has the apple ecosystem
behind it works great with my macbooks
works great with my apple watch
people love it they're stuck in that
system and that's a definite plus even
if it has a lot of other downfalls
the note 20 it has the s pen now i have
to be honest
i usually only use this for the first
maybe a week or so and then i end up
using my notes
like regular phones i've done that ever
since the original note
a lot of people love this though if
you're somebody that wants to draw
you want to write this thing is
excellent having that capability and
samsung has now updated this
with extremely little lag this matches
up to the
uh basically the ipad pro now with this
120 hertz screen you guys could see
compared to the samsung tablets this is
way better
at least until that s7 plus comes out
and it will match up with this but if
you're somebody
that can appreciate the s pen that is
definitely a huge
bonus now let's get into the final
conclusion
what do i think about these two phones
well
if you're not stuck in the apple
ecosystem i really like the note i love
the way it looks i love the way it feels
i love that it's lightweight even though
the screen is huge
it comes in at 300 bucks you do get
double the storage
but along with that you get the 5g
capability
which is really nice the two things that
really bugged me about my iphone
is the ram i'm a power user and
there's four gigs is just not enough in
the fact that the modem is just quite a
bit slower noticeably slower than the
samsung phones especially with 5g
we have sub 6 here it's about twice as
fast
and then it gets a better reception as
well which is a big deal so i'm really
looking forward to the next week
at least the next week maybe permanently
switching over to the note 20 and being
able to use this device so make sure you
guys are subscribed to have those
notifications enabled for the great
videos that we have upcoming
that's been max and i'll see you in the
next video